[Music]  fifth harmony took home their first moon  man  since Camila Cabello departure the group  won best pop video for their song down  at Sunday's MTV Video Music Awards  [Music]  during the group's acceptance speech the  ladies got a bit teary-eyed over the  honor this is honestly so unreal this is  such a monumental moment for us right  now this is so special  dinah gucci normani lauren I love y'all  so much I'm so glad we're in this  together and I had a vision for us and  I'm just so grateful far we've come and  I love you guys with all my heart  shortly after their win the foursome  kicked off their performance with a bold  statement here they are literally  throwing a fifth member off the VMA  stage seemingly representing former  bandmate Camilla  [Applause]  you